games that are better on their hardest
difficulties mm-hmm and by that we can
be pretty flexible maybe like there's
there an alternate difficulty like a
survival mode Robbie you've done a
couple videos last year about this for a
couple different games so let you start
it off but essentially just games that
you can enjoy more when they're at their
hardest yeah it's it's really
interesting too because dating back to
the fallout for survival mode sometimes
a game I feel like for example fallout
where you know later in the game you
become so overpowered and I think you
hear that even maybe with Dishonored I
think Scott had the same sentiment we're
like when the game just gets almost
boring where you feel like so
overpowered like that's kind of like a
solution is to have a survival mode or
play the game differently with like no
powers right for Dishonored
fallout 4 was one of those games where
was like I have a hundred and thirty
stems at the ready
there is never gonna be a moment where
I'm how our armor yeah power I might
play hanyan I'm just plowing through
this game I don't feel like a survivor
anymore I think the early stages of the
game do really well right and that's so
fallout right so you kind of lose that
uh and that's why survival mode was so
cool was it just in so many areas
limited like how much you could take
with you so instead of you know adding
weight to stims
means I can't take 130 I can only take
like maybe five also when I can when I
use them they are not immediate
they don't replenish my health
immediately so it's like a slow burn
yeah so when you're in combat and not
get out of jail free cards really just a
resort when you have to get out of a
fight or just gradually while you're
getting wounded still hey there were so
many things in that in that mode that
like really like just made the game so
much better and made everything seem so
dire like being in a fight and having
you know the only way you can save the
game is by sleeping in a bed so it's
like crap I haven't saved I mean it's
pretty brutal but like I haven't saved
in an hour I'm in this fight I'm about
to die your heart just like picks up and
you know
adrenaline hi like it's it was cool to
like have that again and as far as last
year goes so many games were doing that
you know I mean if L like every other
month was like oh far cry has a survival
mode oh you know division now has a
survival mode which I haven't played yet
divisions that one sounds pretty fun
actually yeah it's a totally different
game oh yeah that's hyperbolic it's very
very different it it's the same game map
did you play it Kelly mm-hmm you uh did
you play to the division no I barely did
either but from what I played I played
more survival than I did the base game
because I liked it that much more it's
yeah you're fighting to get to the
center it actually feels I think it's
kind of long what you're saying will
fall out for the Boston wasteland it
feels like it fits more in the world
this post-apocalyptic New York City you
know winter like virus this virus
induced winter and actually yeah right
now another example that I didn't write
down I want to get to you Jacob Decker
as a big fan of Last of Us as a lot of
people are but someone else
Hans el Hans Nell I forgive me if I'm
mispronouncing that in the YouTube chat
sets last of us grounded mode and I
totally agree but for the same have you
even heard of that oh yeah for the same
reason it's it's just it's much harder
like in terms of how much it's more
realistic in terms of how much damage
Joel can take before he dies or these
gets wounded crafting they're much
sparser items you have two managers a
pot supplies much more fastidious I I
love the resource management aspect
right yeah the ground and mode makes it
better because you're worrying so much
more in the long run like because ivory
playing the game you're like okay [ __ ] I
have this stuff coming up in Pittsburgh
or I know in Iowa this is gonna go down
sand I'm I want like enough items for
this to be manageable and it fits within
the world right again it's a
post-apocalyptic world where you're just
coming across these household items that
you're fashioning into SHIVs or you know
ammo yeah I like that it may it forces
you to pay more attention because I mean
if you're replaying the game for you
know a third or fourth time because I
love last of us like I always feel like
playing it it you know what's coming up
and it makes a lot more sense to have to
plan for our head I feel like I do that
in games anyway like a lot of games
where I'm like oh I won't use this
potion because what if I need it
in five hours and then I never use it
and we're as ungrounded you do end up
using everything you have because you
have so little and I think that makes
the experience a lot better right for
sure it and I same with the division
same with fallout 4 it kind of just
feels more at home with in the world
they build same with even Resident Evil
right like amount of bullets you have
like five bullets or on a harder
difficulties despite how action-oriented
that game is the item management is much
more enticing on harder difficulty I
think and trying to manage it right and
even things like titanfall we've talked
about where I played that on normal it
off the bat like that game was just way
too easy on its normal mode but you put
it on master you are approaching like
these areas you know like you know that
in that in that game there's like that
one those ticks yeah I forget that's the
second or third map where these ticks
are just some bots kind of thing you're
just constantly running and you you that
you know that game is very much not a
cover based shooter it's a wall running
shooter this mode and this mode is
different than the other games were
talking about in that it encourages you
to play the game in a very different way
than you might others shooters and I
would argue like in the way that it
should be played which is like keep
moving the game is even you know the
game is trying to reinforce the idea
that like you know it says it even
though as a death screen like keep
moving and that's a play multi-player so
having that like having played like half
of that game on master I still want to
beat it kind of just clicked for me was
like I just gotta keep moving like right
which was something that I didn't have
to do in the normal normal mode of the
game so yeah it's it's it's the e of
just looking at different approach of
like making a game harder like can
strengthen or reinforce it's like
McCormick's annex or like how the game
is meant to be played mm-hmm
and I found that interesting yeah you
did videos on both titanfall 2 and
follow for survival mode both of which
you're saying kind of these are this is
the way this game should be played do
you think these games would both be
better on these difficulties for the
first playthrough or just something you
should try once you like beat it alright
for titanfall I would say yeah I mean I
guess both these I would wreck
like later unless you're like really
great at shooters or one with titanfall
I would recommend that you know at least
like at the second hardest mode fallout
was if like I can I could not imagine
playing that game off the bat like in
the beginning with survival mode like
you it's so brutal like already it's
like you have nothing yeah no stems
nothing and you just step outside like I
feel like a radroach we're just like
bite your head off right yeah yeah for
sure I do want to call it a couple for
get to Kali if you had a knee you wanted
to mention I had one that's sort of
cheating if I over yeah do it I really
want to shout out under tails genocide
run um if you aren't familiar with
undertale
there's several there I think there's
like seven or so endings but if you play
through a first place here in just plain
normally you get like a pretty normal
ending and if you play genocide where
you kill literally everything in the
game there's this phenomenal final boss
that it's it took me two weeks to be I
played every night for two weeks chooses
to memorize it so it's the combatant
undertale is like sort of bullet hell so
i played every night i would come home
from work and play and i finally beat it
was like the most satisfying i've ever
done and it the mode itself i mean it's
not technically a mode it's just like
you can choose to play the game that way
which is why this is cheating a little
bit but I think it really enhances the
point of that mode which is a undertale
is a lot about personhood and agency and
that's a lot of what the games about and
it really drives at home really well
especially if you play this a second
time so this is another one I think you
wouldn't want to play it for the first
time doing that but I would recommend
like if you've already beaten undertale
playing through it again
killing literally everything but super
coincidental unfortunate I actually just
finally got undertale on Steam maybe
I'll check that out if like if I like
the game enough to do a second
playthrough he'll try that out I did
want to talk about some what so 0 again
sorry from butchering this but 0hx cf7
mentioned Metro 2033 is Ranger mode
Metro last light a similar difficulty
which that's very much a similar vein as
the games we were talking about in terms
of the survival being a lot
more intense and you have to be a lot
more careful fastidious with your items
I've loved Metro last light I liked 2033
but like after playing lat Last Light
2033 kind of pales in comparison I want
to talk about Far Cry primal they
brought out a survival mode as well and
you know how it kind of when the Sun
Goes Down in that game that's when the
Predators come out you want to have a
fire or at least like a torch to kind of
word wolves away but this is very much
the same thing you don't have as much of
an interface so it feels more like
you're just kind of in this world the
cold is much more damaging to you once
you go into the northern sections of the
game I think this game was a little bit
forgettable because it was sort of along
the Far Cry 3 4 it was it was a far cry
3 for clone just in the Stone Age but I
think they actually made good use of it
especially with the survival mode it was
much harder - it felt it felt just as
brutal as the story was trying to tell
you the game was as opposed to the first
playthrough which I still really liked
actually but I I actually might
recommend playing this game for the
first time in the survival mode because
if especially if you played Far Cry 3 &
4 and looking for something truly
different to feel like this caveman
surviving in this dangerous world where
like the animals in the environment are
more almost more of a threat to you than
the humans are I think you people if you
have not played Far Cry primal yet which
you know it didn't really get a lot of
game before game of the year or anything
or any accolades or awards but I think
it is an underrated game and I think
people should play it in survival mode
did the in that mode that sounds
interesting like the whole night aspect
because that was something about that
game where it seemed missed because
again if I remember correctly you could
just walk back to a campfire and sleep
out the night yeah did they remove that
if they remove that that'd be cool I
believe fast travel is not in survival
that's cool right then you're like see
you see the Sun going right that's right
they did remove I remember that that
needed to happen that is because then
you're like you hear a sabertooth kind
of like howling right howling what do
they do
screeching sure yeah the saber-tooth
swooping down to grab you right um and
yes I actually would tell people to play
it this is one of those few games I
would say play this on the hardest
difficulty first because I think you'll
appreciate this game more it sets itself
apart from Far Cry 3 and Far Cry 4 a
little more unless one I wanted to
mention
XCOM 2 is Ironman and XCOM enemy
unknowns Ironman mode this is the
permadeath mode I don't think you're
playing ex-con the right
if you don't have permit death enabled
if you want to reload a save and try to
redo something I don't think you're
getting the full impact that game ex-con
2 was one of my favorite games last year
I'd never play next kind of yet I played
the next calm one playthrough out of my
60 playthroughs of XCON games
not with perma death and I think that's
because you don't feel the impact of
losing someone just much like Fire
Emblem you won't feel the impact of that
unless you're actually losing these
people for good you start getting
attached to these snipers not because
like their character models or their
their dialogue cheesy dialogue but
because you're like oh [ __ ] I just lost
my my Brazilian sniper who had like 65
confirmed kills her weapon was outfitted
really well I lost that I lost all her
good armor like you actually feel it and
then you there's a genuine like
disappointment and like regret knowing
like if I just thrown this flashbang at
this point or killed this mute on it
like crushes you like really good pick I
would actually say XCOM that's the same
thing XCOM should be played at iron man
I don't think you're playing XCOM if
you're not on Ironman mode that reminds
me
Fire Emblem on classic mode yeah you're
not playing fire on Plymouth Fury
if you can't lose your potential husband
I don't think that counts I've been
waiting to get into fireman games I
played awakening a little bit but I
sadly I did not get more into it but uh
there's more a fan of fates or we talked
about yeah I think so but yeah I broken
record I guess but um sorry Monro one
night she said real life has permit
earth I play game to the escape that's a
valid concern that's yeah I mean maybe
if you're new to Fire Emblem I would say
play it on the not permit dev yeah but
the thing is I'm the kind of person I
always reset a game if something I don't
like happens and so my challenge to
myself is not to do that yeah but it's
the same thing where it's like oh I lost
this person that had these skills that I
really needed
like now I have to go on and figure out
how to go on without that or my wife who
died no yeah yeah it's because fire on
them once you get with a little farther
in the game the meta becomes more about
like building relationships and whatnot
right yeah okay yeah well and then you
like it's sort of weird we have to like
kind of breed people for better children
who can be soldiers genetic engineering
mmm
cool sure but I I do think a lot of
people care about the relationship
aspect in firing them so that does have
that emotional effect in addition to the
disappointment of like oh I lost my best
healer or whatever it is right right
yeah cuz you could play the XCOM 2 on
easy but still have Ironman mode enabled
or rookie and still have Iron Man 2 so
the actual enemies a little user but you
still lose people so I think if you're
playing for the first time go on rookie
but set Ironman mode I can be mistaken
about this but I think eat like rookie
has on your man mode either way I'm just
like talking backs come to but I'm gonna
shut up yeah so those are the ones we
wanted to mention but if anybody
watching right now wants to throw a few
more of the chat we've seen like no the
Last of Us Metro 2033 both great picks
leave your thought in the comments and
we'll peruse them and try to get back to
you thanks
[Music]